foreign
we're going to kick it off with Josh in
Tampa this hour Josh what's going on
hi George hi Dr John thank you guys so
much for taking my call sure
um yeah so my wife and I are on baby
step 3B and we've never had any debt as
a married couple and she's brought up a
couple times now that we should get a
credit card to build our credit for when
we're ready to buy a house and I was
just wondering how uh how can I softly
and lovingly explain to her that the
risk isn't worth the very little reward
that comes with having a credit card how
long have you been married dude
we have been married for about a year
and a half yeah I was thinking you've
been married less than two years so you
still think softly and gently works
[Laughter]
I'm just playing it's all good all right
so
um
George I'll let you do the honors well
I'm I'm curious Josh
obviously you are in the boat of we
don't need the credit score right right
and she's in the boat of like why would
we not it's going to make our life
easier does she know about manual
underwriting if you explain that it's
not that difficult to get a house
without a credit score if you do it the
right way
yes I have explained that to her she's
she's come at it I guess she's come at
it from The Stance of
yeah that's true but if we did have a
really good credit score we could get an
even better interest rate and I I don't
I just ended up telling her that I would
feel really uncomfortable getting a
credit card and so it hasn't it hasn't
come up to a boiling point of a full-on
fight I just want to
like stop it before it gets to that
point well the other piece of this is
there's a lot of misinformation out
there when it comes to getting a house
without a credit score that you're going
to get a horrible interest rate and as
someone who's actually done it they
don't care about my opinion of course
they just go but the truth is that you
can get a great rate without a credit
score
if you get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
with 20 down I will get the same score
as the guy next to me who has a great
excellent credit score
right but if you told her that what
would her response be
is she wanting to do a 30-year is she
wanting to put less down where's the
hold up here when it comes to buying the
house
well the um I I think we're just feeling
a little discouraged in terms of buying
a house because we we live in a really
high rent area and you know she wants to
wait and we both really want to wait to
get to have kids until we are in a house
and so there's kind of I think a lot of
emotions tied up into getting a house as
quick as possible so I think that's
playing a bit of a role in
her looking at other ways to get in one
quickly so my guess is she wants to put
as little down possible and do a 30-year
mortgage
we definitely had had conversations of
doing the 30-year mortgage
have you guys been through Financial
Peace University
uh no we haven't I've grown up of you
know my parents grew up on Dave Ramsey
and so I've you know I followed his test
and I was a big fan but to her this is
all new information you're coming at her
sideways and it's creating some tension
very true yeah because you're used to
this stuff this is like mind-blowing
jarring information to her
so she I think she also needs some time
with it under she needs to understand it
at a deeper level and you guys need to
be more aligned on those that vision and
those goals here's here's where I would
start if I were you and I was kind of
giving you a hard time about only being
married 18 months I think this is
actually the perfect time for y'all
I would love to see y'all go on what I I
wish I had another word for it man
because this is so corporate language
but I would love to see y'all go on some
sort of strategic planning retreat
and here's what you're just here's what
you're discovering and here's what
you're etching into stone
here's who we are gonna be
this is the kind of family we're gonna
be and I want you to etch your values I
want you to Anchor them into the Bedrock
of of your soul and I want you to hold
your beliefs really really lightly
what I mean by that is value we are a
people we're a family that never borrows
money
I also believe I wanna I I should have a
house before I have kids
I'm gonna never touch that value that
value is etched into into stone we just
don't borrow money this is who we are I
don't build a build up a credit score
whatever the heck that is get some
Airline point we're just we just don't
borrow money this is Who We Are
we don't cheat on each other we don't
punch each other in the face we don't
murder we just these are just things we
don't do
and we have this belief we have to have
a house where we have kids I'm gonna
hold that one real Loosely and I'm gonna
go talk to some people who have had a
bunch of kids before
one of the greatest experiences of my
life was the two years or the one year
we lived in an apartment when my son was
two it was a blast
we got to know my neighbors he got to
see it was amazing and never in a
million years would have done that right
so that's a belief that I held really
Loosely that I got some new wisdom on
but when it comes to values you guys
haven't had the who are we gonna be yet
y'all are still arguing on the plays you
want to run you're not arguing what kind
of team we're gonna be and that's where
I want to see you spend your energy on
the front end
and that take tends to take a lot of the
nuts and bolts questions off the table
because it's just who we are
right
and I think every new married couple
could benefit from that I I mean you've
been married 25 years you need to have
another one of those strategic plans who
are we now where are we what do we
believe what do we want to be about
about in this season but man I think
that's where I'd start is hey honey what
kind of Life Do You Want to Build
Together
who do we want to be
and then when you decide I want to be a
house that never does this cool we're in
now you're gonna sit with somebody who's
way smarter than me like George and he's
going to walk you through okay well
here's how you buy a house in here's how
you do this thing here's how you buy a
car then here's how you become a
millionaire
uh-huh Josh a lot of people ask me hey
man you you got a house you paid it off
early you did it without a credit score
what do you attribute to that and 100
it's being on the same page with my wife
we pre-decided all of these things we
pre-decided we were gonna save up a huge
down payment pre-decided we're gonna do
a 15-year pre-decided that we're going
to go through the process of manual
underwriting and that changes the game
it made us move so much faster than us
bickering over the tactics so you and
your wife go listen to the episode of
the fine print that I did it's called
the dirty truth behind your credit score
have a listen to that I'm also going to
gift you guys Financial Peace University
because I think she just doesn't have
all the information and you've had it
for years and so to you it's a
no-brainer to her this is still
she's figuring out why do we have to
live outside of the Matrix The Matrix is
a great place to live it's comfortable
in there the pill we can get out and so
I think with time and like John said
that intentional planning you guys will
get there so I hang on the line Emily's
gonna pick up we're going to give to you
one year Financial Peace University
we're wishing you the best with the
house buying process